Beijing's imposing skyline has all but
vanished behind a thick veil of smog on
Thursday a pollution particles rose to
their highest level in months measuring
as high as 671 micrograms per cubic
meter
that's nearly 26 times the amount
considered safe by the World Health
Organization people here are no
strangers to smog but current levels
have many worried about their health the
air pollution is very serious so I wear
my face mask because of it I've gotten a
nose infection and today it's really bad
the pollution is really bad I've been
battling with a terrible cold for days I
have difficulty breathing I'm coughing
up phlegm I want to get out of Beijing I
don't want to stay here pollution here
usually goes from bad to worse in winter
when many turned to coal for heating
authorities say they're planning to
switch to gas they also want to curb
traffic and manufacturing when hazardous
levels are forecast for three days or
more
but Beijing's residents will have to
hang on to their masks for just a little
longer
the smog is expected to last for at
least another day